قد يعود الانسان من سفر طويل او غياب لم
يكن محدد وقت انتهائه لكن العوده من الموت
هي الامر الاكثر غرابه حادثه غريبه صدمت
الشريعه المصري وقعت تفاصيلها في قريه قرب
المنوفيه في مصر تلخصت بعوده ميت بعد دفنه
بشهر تفاصيل القصه وقعت حين دفنت عائله
مصريه فقيده المدعو محمد عادل الذي افترض
انه توفي بحادث سياره وتم دفن جثته بعد
السلامها لكن محمد عاد بعد شهر من الدفن
والعزاء ليصدم عائلته وجيرانه الذين لم
يصدقوا الامر في بدايته ليكون السؤال
الاهم عندهم من هو المدفونه سؤال تحقق
السلطات المصريه حاليا لمعرفه هويه الجثه
المدفونه
[موسيقى]
عاده بعد الشهر من مفروض دفنه
يعني بالعاده نحن بنقول قطه بسبع ارواح بس
انسان بسبع ارواح هاي جديده يعني في في
يعني اكيد في شغله هيك شغاله بسيطه نحن
لسه مش فاهمينها في القصه
بتتعلق بانه اختفاءه شهر وبعدين رجع انه
عيلته اه بس هم بيقولوا لك انه ممكن دفنو
جوسته اخرى هون اللبس يعني مش عارفين اي
جثه كم دفنها لانه بيكون الميت مغطى بعيد
عن الجميع وبتقول
يسرا انهم تلقوا اتصال باحتجازه بالعنايه
المركزه في مستشفى وبعدين اتعرفوا عليه
تخيلي انه يعني فعلا تعرفوا على هذه الجثه
وتم دفنه لكن رغم ذلك تم دفن شخص اخر اه
هو مفروض توفى في حادث سير ندوهم ليتعرفوا
على الجثه ويتعرفوا عليها فعلا وبيقولوا
لك انه تم الجفن دفن جثه لا تخص هذا الشخص
اصلا طب صوره تتحقق في من المدفون